you are all persons of interest in this
case someone's trying to frame this
this is gonna be fine
it could be bad this is an amazing
season even i loved it even more than
season one you seem to be annie
i loved it so much um this could be a
very off-the-wall question however there
is a wonderful use of a parrot this
season there's some great scenes between
your characters and a parrot
if said parrot was to follow the three
of you around as you're work shopping
behind the scenes on set for the entire
season
what do you think it would repeat back
to you at the end of the season
uh
shut up
no i think i don't i have no idea
actually probably the same jokes that we
tell all the time yeah my independent
who you know if it was following steve
would be going no more art no more art
talk no more art no more badges
i get i would get marty's not that funny
he's not that funny
got it i love it i love it um one of the
lines the the one-liners in the show are
so incredible i'm i always write down
one-liners after watching an episode so
that i don't forget them and one of my
favorite ones this season is when
selena's character you're in the
elevator with martin's character and he
says something to her about something
that happened in his past i think
somebody he hooked up with and she says
that's a lie and he says you get me you
really get me don't you i'm wondering
for each of you as you were filming this
season i know um stephen martin you've
known each other for a long time what
was the moment that you looked at each
other was just like you just get me you
just really get me
um i've never had that with steve but
yeah
yeah when did you i have oh i think i
got you when i was poking a little dig
at you and you said i've taught you well
i always say you really don't get me do
you
okay so after all of these years
um
i know you've probably been asked this a
lot about sort of like why this dynamic
between the three of you works but if
you can sort of like maybe go around
robin and just tell me one thing that
the other person brought to this season
that you just loved like you just loved
about
the other person and sort of what their
character sort of how it evolved in
season two so maybe i'll start with
selena you can choose either gentleman
and name one thing you loved
um well i love
i love steve's earnestness
i think it's very sweet and i love the
wackiness that ensues with this one oh i
love that yeah that's a hard to follow
um i like
when i see selena on the screen there is
so much going on it's not just the
dialogue there's so much
going on either pain
or realizations ahead of something and
it's a very multi-layered face that miss
gomez has that is awfully awfully
gratifying
uh especially to work with
steve
you know yeah
for me you know
selena brings a kind of third point in
the triangle that just throws us marty
and me off balance or our character's
off balance so we always it's almost
like
uh after every one of
selena's characters lines
my character wants to go
huh
you know and kind of work it out
afterwards but and of course marty and i
have go back a long way so i yes you
know we liked the precision timing that
we maybe have developed over the years
was there anything that went totally off
the rails that ended up on the cutting
room floor this season that they just
couldn't add into the season because of
time constraints or storyline but i'm
imagining you're workshopping throughout
and you're practicing bits and you're
doing different things i was gonna say
the one thing i thought was funny was av
amy amy schumer had so many lines that
obviously because of timing and the
length of the seed but she was killing
me on set it was really fun but that's
the only million lines yeah you've kind
of led me to my next question i know i'm
already thinking ahead to season three
there's always an incredible penthouse
person living in the penthouse it was
sting then it was amy who is your dream
penthouse occupant for season three and
is there a journey dream scenario that
you would love to have play out between
the three of you
i would like it i'd like it to be steven
spielberg and it turns out that he's the
killer
that's a good one brilliant i don't know
i i would be so happy if you know
i mean anyone who joins our show i
personally have been a huge fan of tina
fey so
being able to work with her is is a
highlight for sure yeah goes for me too
i would like to see
maybe
mitch mcconnell
move in
because that would mean he wasn't doing
his other job
i'll i'll leave it at that i'll i'll
leave that one there you touched a
little bit upon sort of like the
generational gap between the between the
three of you and i know that selena you
know have fans that were previously
martin and steve's
fans and vice versa you've sort of
picked up fan bases from each other's
perhaps a generation or genre you know
time um is there a particular fan
encounter or something that was really
sweet or unexpected that the three of
you experienced
well i don't know if if um i've never
told steve this but one of my best
friends watched some of the show with me
and she started crying because she was
like i just feel like
he's so precious that he's so kind did i
just thought it was really it was really
darling to hear and then one time i was
at a restaurant
and an older gentleman came up to me and
he was just so sweet and i didn't know
what he was gonna say honestly i didn't
think he
even knew who i was but he was just like
you are wonderful in that one show with
steve martin and martin shorts and i'm
like thank you so much and
it was just really sweet
and either of you gentlemen anything
from perhaps a younger demo or younger
crowd well we had steven spielberg come
and hang out in the set because he's a
fan of the show that was kind of cool
wow quite the younger crowd but i think
for the younger crowd you know we say
i mean marty and i both say
we want a generation gap we don't we
don't want to be
you know 25 and have all those
sensibilities uh and it sort of makes
when we when there is a generation gap
it makes life more interesting
absolutely no that's what i think that's
the brilliance of the show is the
dynamic between the three of you not
telling you anything you don't already
know um suddenly debate my last question
there's a reference to the wizard of oz
this season which i absolutely love just
near and dear to my heart if there was a
reboot of the wizard of oz which
character would each of you like to play
well obviously dorothy
yeah i didn't know if you were going to
go against type selena and pick
something else
or
what's her name
glenda
linda
billy billy her name is billy burke come
on come on
i would say
um i'm gonna go with the scarecrow
i'm going with the wizard
because it's
one day's work behind a curtain
you